talk about you talk about empathy and
perspective and building relationships
as a leader but I look at leader a
leader like Steve Jobs who's known for
his hostile attitude toward people isn't
that being default aggressive like you
talk about if I'm more naturally that
type of leader should I go with it if it
worked for Steve Jobs shouldn't it work
for me so that's a good question and I
haven't actually read the book about
Steve Jobs and I think there's probably
more than one but there's the one that's
real popular real thick and someone gave
it to me and I have it and I will
someday but I haven't read it yet and
I've heard it's really good and all that
and I that being said I've I've heard
the same things about you know Steve
Jobs that leadership style and he was
real tyrannical and I pulled a couple
things here just from well here we go in
his book about jobs time at next and
returned to Apple the second coming of
Steve Jobs Allen dushman described jobs
rough treatment of his underlings he
would praise as a quote he would praise
and inspire them often in very creative
ways but he would also resort to
intimidating goading berating belittled
littling and even humiliating them so
and there's another article by Ronald
regio who's a PhD in psychology and the
article came from Psychology Today and
it says he was obsessively controlling
and given to fits of rage throwing
tantrums and yelling at employees and
board members he could tear down
someone's ideas or the person himself in
a public display some have said he took
credit for others ideas and his
confidence led to a sort of over-the-top
arrogance so the guys kind of tyrannical
one time when they were putting together
the MobileMe application and it wasn't
working well and jobs told the team that
was putting it together you when it
wasn't working you've tarnished Apple's
reputation you should hate each other
for having let each other down
so okay so first of all let's look at
the fact that you've heard me say this
before that people's strengths are their
weaknesses and their weaknesses can be
their strengths so in Steve Jobs case
obviously some of this stuff some of his
weaknesses that we're talking about here
were also strengths because he was
totally beyond driven right he was
completely obsessed with with doing good
and all that and and he pressed toward
his vision extremely hard he was
relentless in trying to make things
happen and again those are very positive
characteristics if you got someone
that's really driven and they're driven
to the point of almost being obsessed
and you you take that and those are kind
of good characteristics but when they go
too far this is why it's dichotomy this
is a balance of leadership right when
you go too far you become a tyrannical
leader which is not good it's not good
for a team and it's and it's and a team
that is subjected to that kind of
attitude will not perform as well as a
unified team period period so the guy
was clearly hostile and at the same time
clear clearly he was one of the most
successful business leaders in history
right so would you look at him and say
okay well maybe I should be that way
maybe I should be a tyrannical leader
and I would say to that no you do not
get to do that and here's why let's look
at some other characteristics that Steve
Jobs had first of all he was perhaps the
foremost technological visionary in the
history of the world right I mean he had
a vision of technology that very few
people in the history in the world of
had and I will go a little bit more
narrow I think he understood things on a
note another level when it came to
technology that the part of how human
beings would interact with technology
that's the part that I think he really
had just incredible vision for he
realized like oh these people won't want
a computer in their house and they'll
want it to reflect the way they live and
they're gonna want music in their pocket
they're gonna want
all of their music in their pocket and
they're gonna want a phone that can do
it you know he had this vision of how
people would interact with technology
that I don't think too many people have
hmm so so that's number one
number two he had a phenomenal feel for
design right for design and how to merge
form and function together in in an in
an aesthetically pleasing and an
oftentimes stunning way if you look at
the design and that's uncommon
especially for someone to have that feel
for design and still have a massively
technical background right so so that
again we're making a person that's like
1% of 1% of 1% already on top of that he
got into business his business at the
right time in the right place he had the
right background on top of that the guy
could speak well the guy was very
articulate right he was very articulate
with his vision if you do you watch his
keynote speeches that he would give at
the whatever it is when they have the
Apple Convention what's that thing
called the Apple come in yeah they have
that thing well he get up on stage and
he'd talk about something and he would
articulate that and he would do it with
real clarity and he was very convincing
and he was very captivating and people
were you know they'd say apples a cult
mmm they'd follow that guy so he had all
those skills those world-class skills
and I'm not using that term lightly I'm
talking world-class skills and then
they're all those world-class skills are
combined together into one package one
human being and there you got you got
Steve Jobs so he's got all those
advantages and then on top of that he's
had some luck along the way right he had
some luck in his timing and his
upbringing and in the exposures that he
got and being exposed to computer
programming and those things back in the
day was rare and he got lucky and having
that unfold from so he had all these
things going for him that helped propel
him and his company to the top
so now if you're thinking maybe you
should use his leadership style the the
questions that you should ask yourself
is are you a one-in-a-billion the
technological visionary or visionary of
any kind the answer that is likely no
and if you think it's yes maybe you
should check your ego a little bit then
you have to ask yourself do you have an
eye for design an artistic eye for
design like like da Vinci or
Michelangelo if you have that you
probably don't if you think you have
that maybe you should check your ego
again
are you a gifted speaker and storyteller
and can you convey your vision with
total clarity two big giant groups broad
groups of people and if you think you
can do that again you should check your
ego can you count on luck or do you want
to count on luck too to close the gaps
in some of those other areas so if you
could do all those things if you
answered yes a hundred percent to all
those questions and okay maybe you can
get away with being a kind of leader
that Steve Jobs was but if you're a
normal person if you're a normal human
being then maybe you should try and be a
good leader and maybe you should be a
leader that builds relationships and
forms cohesive teams and coalition's
that help you drive your mission forward
despite the ups and downs of whatever
business you're in so that's it Steve
Jobs had a lot of other things that made
him successful
yeah and leadership and he I've got to
eventually read the book but he clearly
had some people around him that that
utilized that skill the skills that he
did had and have and moved and helped
move him forward right and other people
at the company other people early and in
Apple we saw that hey you know what this
guy he might be a little bit hard to
deal with but he's got some things that
we won't find anywhere else
so let's prop him up
let's move forward yeah and that's
that's the way it works yeah I think
they call that survivorship bias where
like you see oh you see a successful
granule yeah yeah he did it that way so
let's do it that way um but yeah you you
kind of don't see all the other factors
or whatever
almost like you if you really think
about it if Steve Jobs were to be like
in these tyrannical ways or what if you
were to be less like that maybe there
would be more Super Saiyan but he was so
strong in these other areas that it kind
of like mitigated the effects you know
there's there's businesses that are
successful because they're a successful
business model and they have really bad
leadership yeah and even that kinda
thing that yep even the bad leadership
doesn't it's the the model is so good
yeah which is a little bit contrary
because you know I would say leadership
the most important thing on the
battlefield but in the business world if
you have a phenomenal idea then you can
you can be successful on that idea alone
now that is that is a unicorn that is
one of those rare things where you have
something that's that incredibly
different and stands out from the crowd
so much that it's gonna be successful no
matter what you know when the when the
early gyms MMA type gyms if you had one
you were successful didn't matter what
kind of leader you were because you add
you had it yeah and and now there's
competition if you're not if you have
good leadership and you're not putting
forth a good product amongst all their
competitors you're gonna have problems
yeah you're gonna have problems with it
yeah and the more I kind of listen to
you and life the more I realize that
even then the like it's almost like you
have to have a minimum level of
leadership like you don't be have to be
perfect if you have the one of these
situations where the product of the
business model so good but still even
your leadership can mess that oh yeah
you can absolutely because you yeah like
you're in a situation where it's like no
now no one wants to work for you now
what oh yeah good nice and I'm a gym you
don't have any you got to work there
yeah you know the whole time and you
can't you know so it's gonna kind of
fall apart after a while so maybe like
it in the beginning it'd be good but
it'll fall apart because he you sure for
sure and you you can see that who's the
guy that just got removed from uber I'd
have to go into D I'd I have to really
drill down
but the CEO of uber got removed and you
know the business models awesome yeah
and they still remove the CEO why
because there's there's issues there
yeah
and so well it's a great business model
but we still need good leadership yeah
so yeah like you like it I'm basically
confirming what you just said the good
business model will get you to a certain
level but then to get to the next level
and you're gonna need leadership and
that's why we just it's the most
important thing on the battlefield so
what the morale don't necessarily be
tyrannical no in fact don't be straight
up a radical yeah don't be and I'm not
saying that there's not times where you
have to have a little tyrannical flair
because there there may be times where
you need to where you need to flare up a
little bit yeah but it should be rare
yeah it should be rare the problem is it
becomes a crutch for people and then
they just continue to do it more and
more and more and more and then it
doesn't work it's like it's kind of like
drugs - right the like when you like
when you flare up on someone and you win
or whatever yeah you know you kind of
like it works yeah it worked and you
kind of like it feels good feels
powerful hmm so I think some people
that's how you know so they'll do it and
it'll work and they'll be like yeah I
don't need that little yeah and what's
even worse is like when you win that's
where you you learn from someone that's
what you saw and then do you do it and
you don't work for me - and I'll have to
be his treat people bad and be a jerk
and yell and the my subordinates will do
what I tell them to do and they will
right the subordinate will if you bark
at them and scream at them they're gonna
do what you say at the moment mm-hmm the
problem is what kind of team of you
built that's a problem yeah what does
that support they're gonna do when
you're not there they're gonna do
everything they can to cut corners and
and really they don't care about they
don't care about you they don't want to
do a good job for you
yeah so when you're not there they're
not gonna do a good job for you yeah so
you get addicted to yelling and
screaming but it doesn't work in the
broad sense of what you're trying to
make happen
yeah really falling apart